our las vegas tradition continues this
weekend the las vegas days parade is
going to march right through downtown
las vegas and here to talk about it
marsha biggest from the city of las
vegas good to see you thank you very
much for coming in good to see you now
for longtime folks here in town we know
las vegas days
used to be eldorado but it's the same
flair same everything else let's talk
about what we can see at the parade this
year so this year the parade is saturday
may 14th starting at 10 a.m it's from
gas to stuart avenue on fourth street we
have the honor guard kicking it off
followed by the mayor with elvis and his
pink cadillac and then of course city
council and we have like 70 other
entries really amazing entries obviously
the pandemic threw a kink in so many
different things how important was it
for the city to get the parade back
in full force right so last year we did
do things a little differently we did a
reverse parade which was amazing but i
think it's really important to bring
that original parade back bring the
community together
and then we've added a festival to keep
these people downtown
celebrate las vegas birthday the way we
should let's talk about the festival
what what's planned there and how what
can people expect so the festival is
it's going to be amazing we have some
local
artists we have some interactive really
large scale interactive art by first
friday fired up management
we have the local nashville renegades
performing
local
headliner frankie moreno which is really
really big um we have the world's like
best food trucks are going to be there
we have a beer and wine garden and
there's a lot of activities for the
children more than just a parade more
than just a person you know i think also
people think when we think of las vegas
we think we the las vegas trip obviously
and it's such a modern city but it's
it's so neat for a parade like this and
in its past incarnation too just
remember the past of las vegas and it's
sort of outlaw western roots right yeah
so i mean
hell dorado was so important to so many
people i have people that have attended
like the first eldorado their
grandchildren are now in the parade so
it's really important to keep this going
so they should start arriving about 9 30
really the prime real estate the best
spot is going to be on 4th street
between clark and fremont street and we
have added a lot of roving entertainment
throughout the parade route
so that's going to be the best place to
see it again it starts at 10 a.m
probably will be done by 11 and by then
the festival will kick off it's going to
be hot
bring water bring water outside it's
going to be a lot of fun marcia biggest
in the city of las vegas talking about
the las vegas days parade this weekend
thanks for joining us we appreciate it
thank you for having me